(spirited orchestral music)
- [Narrator] This is the
aluminum ball challenge.
- We are doing the aluminum
foil ball challenge.
- [Narrator] It swept
the internet. (knocking)
It was pretty much people making smooth,
shiny balls out of aluminum foil.
It originated in Japan, but
the story doesn't end there.
It gets more meta, because this challenge
actually came from another
tradition in Japan;
and in true Japanese fashion,
that tradition is pretty spectacular.
(soft piano music)
Dorodango is a Japanese art form
in which earth and water are molded
to create a delicate, shiny sphere.
That's a nice way of saying
that these are very fancy mud balls.
And when it comes to
making dorodango in Japan,
Kiyoko Miki is one of the best.
(foreign language)
The process, condensed, goes like this:
Get a clay-based mud;
mix it with hay; this helps
keep it from falling apart.
Roll it into a sphere, and
leave it to dry in the sun.
(foreign language)
And the story doesn't end here,
because where there is
something beautiful,
there is a competition
to prove who is the best.
And Kiyoko is a judge.
This is the annual dorodango
tournament in Tokoname, Japan.
(foreign language)
This year, contestants from all over Japan
have come to showcase their work.
It looks like they've got a winner.
So what does a winning
dorodango look like?
Hmm, very shiny.
(foreign language)
Colored, plain, large, small,
the dorodango is not a one-look pony.
It exemplifies so much
of Japanese culture:
patience, perfection, and the pursuit
of beauty in everyday things.
And they're also pretty cool to look at.